relief in the courtroom when the news
was announced that Alexei Navalny would
at least temporarily be a free man what
happened here shows once again that this
is a politically motivated trial I'd
like to thank everybody who protested
against the sentence and who helped
bring about this new decision thousands
had taken to the streets in Moscow to
protest against his arrest and it was
the prosecution that requested na vonas
released from prison while his
conviction is on appeal he was found
guilty of embezzling nearly four hundred
thousand euros from the state when he
worked as a government adviser the court
gave him a five year jail term
opposition forces believe the trial was
concocted to shut up one of President
Vladimir Putin strongest critics Novotny
has repeatedly taken on Russia's
political elite the lawyer and blogger
had even been mulling a run against
Putin in 2018 his surprise released from
custody can be seen as a small step
forward for the embattled Russian
opposition